so I guess that the New England Patriots
lost in yesterday's Super Bowl I'm not
sure I heard that they played yesterday
I don't know it doesn't really matter
but anyway many of the players from the
winning Philadelphia Eagles are already
saying it's not even been 24 hours since
the end of the game they're refusing to
go to the White House to celebrate their
win with president Donald Trump which is
a tradition not only for the winner of
the Super Bowl but for winners of others
other major sports championships Chris
long and LeGarrette Blount both of whom
were on the winning Patriots team last
year they've already skipped the White
House visit once they're going to do it
again and then Malcolm Jenkins as well
as Torrey Smith have said that they're
not going to be attending so good for
them and I'm not saying this or talking
about this because it's hugely
meaningful in the grand scheme of things
who goes to celebrate winning a sporting
event to the White House with the
president but because I do think it's
important for the thin-skinned Donald
Trump to be reality checked as
frequently as spot as possible I think
that this is a good thing
tens of millions of people maybe even
hundreds of millions of people in the
United States don't like Trump actively
proactively and many of those people are
the prominent people that Donald Trump
would like to have good relationships
with because that's what his personality
is like he wants to be revered he wants
to be seen as a star that everyone wants
to defer to and I'm guessing that upon
hearing the news that many Philadelphia
Eagles are going to be boycotting the
visit he will of course handle it
responsibly and like an adult yeah right
it'll probably lead to a childish racist
rant I have cancelled the invitation to
the White House to the failing fake
Philadelphia Eagles if Martin Luther
King were alive - alive today he would
be personally thanking me for the low
black unemployment rate and the Eagles
only won because the NFL referees are in
tatters the Patriots actually won Bob
Kraft is a great and not
SiC guy and that's it the Eagles don't
even deserve to be here at the White
House this guy's so thin-skinned and
such a snowflake that this stuff even
though it doesn't actually matter in the
grand scheme of things could actually
set Trump off on a six-hour tirade that
if we're lucky gets in the way of him
signing another totally abortive
executive order so listen
congratulations to the Philadelphia
Eagles it was a good game both teams
played hard to quote I don't remember
what athlete and I hope more of the
Philadelphia Eagles say yeah we're just
not going to go and Chris long pointing
out or maybe it was LeGarrette Blount we
are athletes but we see what the
president says we can follow the news
just like anybody else and we can choose
to be activists if we want to be and one
of the things we can do is not go to the
White House and for Eagle so far saying
we won't go and I say congratulations
don't go great decision take a quick
break join us on facebook facebook.com
slash david pakman show our sponsor for
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is brilliant dot org if you watch our
channel or listen to our podcast yeah
you're into politics you're into Daily
News but maybe you want to dig a little
deeper on the program we talked about
climate change
taxes technology political philosophy
but if you really want to understand
these issues at the most fundamental
level you have to familiarize yourself
with what is actually underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy the
hard sciences and the social sciences
and that's where brilliant comes in
brilliant is a truly unique and
innovative online learning service that
allows you to master important
real-world math and science concepts
that means everything from probability
and statistics on one hand to logic and
problem solving on the other and
renewable energy and client climate
science and criminology you name it and
you can get started right the second by
signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman and the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman
we'll get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership one more time that is
brilliant
org slash David Pakman